remember all those conspiracy theories
about how barack obama was not going to
leave the White House after his second
presidential term was over he was a some
said going to declare martial law and
suspend the 2016 election or he was
going to violate every check and balance
that our country has in order to
maintain control and then of course
Barack Obama had never mentioned
anything that would suggest he was going
to do that and he peacefully left on his
helicopter turning over control to
president Donald Trump and if there was
ever a case to be made for an exception
in turning over control to such a
buffoon it kind of would have been
Donald Trump and the upper Akko Bhama as
predicted by any rational clear thinking
person very very peaceful he left
Donald Trump has now retweeted the
suggestion that he should get a six year
term instead of a four year term because
he was robbed of two years from his
presidency by the Muller probe and he
referred to those two years as being
stolen from him not I know you're saying
wait what's Stalin not stolen Stalin but
we'll get to that in a second
there's this disgusting guy named Jerry
Falwell Jr he's the son of the late
Jerry Falwell who in my mind is most
known for blaming 911 on abortionists
and gays and Jerry Falwell Jr tweeted
and Donald Trump subsequently retweeted
a tweet which says after the best week
ever for Donald Trump no obstruction no
collusion New York Times admits Barack
Obama did spy on his campaign and the
economy is soaring I now support
reparations Trump should have two years
added to his first term as payback for
time stolen by this corrupt failed coup
so first of all no that's not
constitutional and if we care about that
then the answer to this is obviously no
but secondly this is a political
statement from a guy whose church is
tax-exempt because churches aren't
supposed to be doing politics now is
doing Paul
on Twitter a violation of the nonprofit
charter that churches have I don't know
for sure the legal experts would have to
fight it out but the IRS should
definitely be looking into this
but Trump sees it and he retweets it and
then he decides to take the idea of
those two stolen years to the next level
Falwell tweeted that on Saturday night
Sunday Donald Trump tweets despite the
tremendous success that I have had as
president including perhaps the greatest
economy and most successful first two
years of any president in history a
laughable claim they have stolen two
years of my our presidency collusion
delusion that we will never be able to
get back the stalin typo is so
ridiculous and so embarrassing ly
hilarious that Donald Trump ended up
deleting the tweet but fortunately we
have it for you anyway but let's get
back to the primary issue here because I
will the the stalin typo is funny but
there's actually a really important
thing here is there a chance Trump will
try to not relinquish control of the
White House whenever this national
nightmare ultimately ends either in two
years or in six years Nancy Pelosi is
now concerned that that something Trump
will do she's concerned that if it's a
very marginal a very small margin by
which Trump loses in 2020 Trump will not
relinquish power or will try not to
Trump has actually said that the only
way Democrats can beat him in 2020 is
voter fraud he said he likes the idea of
the possibility of doing president for
life in the US the way that China has
put in place that possibility under the
current administration and we would
quote maybe try it sometime so as I've
said before I believe that law
enforcement agencies of the United
States will not allow Trump to stay in
power beyond his actual electoral
mandate period but every single person
who when Barack Obama was president was
stoking the fears of Obama's not going
to leave why are you now silent because
there was nothing to suggest that was
something Barack Obama was going to do
Trump has actually floated the
narratives that he can't lose unless
there's foul play that combined with his
malignant narcissism and weaponized
ignorant actually gets us closer than
Obama ever was to a situation where the
president
tries to retain control beyond when he's
actually elected but then the most
disturbing part of it is tons of Trump's
followers agree that he should get an
extra two years the most important thing
here is not Trump's misspelling of
stolen a Stalin it's not that Trump has
actually floated this idea of you know
maybe president for life would be nice
and I can only lose by voter fraud Trump
has a significant number of these
brown-nosing sycophants who think it's
reasonable for Trump to get an extension
to his presidential term they claim to
be constitutional conservatives they
pray at the altar of the Constitution as
if it is a sacred text and then of
course for Trump they make an exception
and this may end up being particularly
relevant when it comes to the statute of
limitations on obstruction of justice
Donald Trump is very heavily
incentivized to stay in power for as
long as possible by legal means by
borderline means or by illegal means not
that it would be successful but he's
incentivized to do it specifically to
avoid indictment on obstruction when he
is lone no longer president will be
talking with some legal experts upcoming
on the show about that and the statute
of limitations on obstruction of justice
and that very important footnote in
Robert Muller's report I believe it's
footnote 1090 or 10 91 which says
whether or not a president is impeached
for the stuff in the Moller report that
would not preclude or be a substitute
for indictment once the president is no
longer president of the United States
this is the slide towards it's this
gradual slide towards despotism or I
think better said would be despotism
hopefully we prevent it we know it's
what Trump would love let me know what
you think I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
we will take a quick break
what a big news weekend which I am glad
to be here to tell you about upcoming so
the House Judiciary Committee has
started the process required to hold
Donald Trump's Attorney General William
Bar in
temped so the first question is what
what does that mean what is what does it
mean to be held in contempt in very
simple terms contempt is when somebody
disobeys or ignores or disrespects the
authority of a duly empowered body now
oftentimes we talk about being held in
contempt of court
but it also applies to legislative
bodies and as in this particular case
we're talking about Congress contempt of
Congress the House of Representatives if
you obstruct the legal work of Congress
which includes ignoring subpoenas not
providing documents this can all be
considered contempt of Congress and
that's exactly what Democrats are
alleging or will allege that William bar
did he failed to comply with legal
congressional subpoenas when Congress
requested the unredacted Robert Muller
report and William bar didn't provide it
now this would just be step one of the
process of actually holding Barr in
contempt and I don't think that's a
process that will ever actually be
followed through to its full conclusion
and I'll explain that in a moment but
step one is for the committee to vote on
this tomorrow Wednesday now it's
important to know that even though Barr
released the redacted report the
unredacted report still has not been
released and chairman of the House
Judiciary Committee Jerry Nadler says
he'd consider postponing tomorrow's vote
on contempt against Barr if bar gives
them the full on redacted report no
indication right now that that's
actually going to happen but the most
interesting thing about this is not the
specifics of getting the unredacted
report I think they should have the
unredacted report the most interesting
thing about this is not whether Barr
will actually be held in contempt
because I don't think he will and I'll
tell you why in a second what's riveting
about this is that this is this contempt
of Congress charge was one of the three
things in the articles of impeachment
against Richard Nixon back in 1974 I
told you last week that Trump 2019 is
looking more and more like Nixon 1974
and yesterday on the show I did a story
outlining how the difference between
2019
1974 isn't that what Nixon did is worse
than what Trump has done it's that
Republicans in the 70s drew the line at
abuses of power of this level even by
people in their party Republicans in
2019 on the other hand don't care about
that they have no such line so that is
why this is so interesting but to get
back to the contempt itself
contempt of Congress against the sitting
Attorney General is unlikely to ever
actually be carried fully out because
when think - what libertarians always
talk about they say the government is an
initiator of force because eventually
men with guns will come for you doesn't
sound like taxation is some kind of
slavery under duress well if you don't
pay your taxes eventually men with guns
show up that actually is a relevant
thing to think about when it comes to
contempt of Congress against William bar
because if the House committee votes to
hold Barr in contempt and then the full
house votes to hold Barr in contempt and
everything else that has to follow from
that and happen to hold Barr in contempt
does happen at some point somebody has
to physically detain William Barr is the
house sergeant at arms I'm going to
physically detain the Attorney General
very difficult to imagine that that's
going to happen is a court a court which
is of course part of the Justice
Department that William bar himself
oversees going to physically detain
William bar hard to imagine that that's
going to happen so the actual holding in
contempt of the Attorney General is more
symbolic than anything but the reason
why it matters is that this is another
one of these striking similarities to
Richard Nixon in 1974 and it is
political theater I mean it's political
theater in the sense that it's about
what it means to think about holding the
Attorney General in contempt rather than
actually trying to get the house
sergeant-at-arms to show up at the
Justice Department and say we're here
for the Attorney General because that is
very difficult to imagine his
going to happen but it also represents
potentially the beginning or the
continuation of this exploding and
Trump's face we'll see how they vote
Wednesday in the House Judiciary that's
just step one and ultimately we'll see
if the unredacted Moeller report comes
out whether the full house ends up
taking this up and how this all impacts
the sort of particulars and logistics
but once again if we think about Trump
2019 Nick's in 1974 you look at those
three articles of impeachment that were
filed against Nixon which ultimately
didn't remove him because Nixon saw the
writing on the wall and resigned in 1974
the three things that were contained in
the articles of impeachment against
Nixon in 74 are all things that the
Moller report provides evidence of
Donald Trump having done and once again
again the general atmosphere is contempt
of Congress by an attorney general gives
us another reminder of Nixon 1974 we'll
follow it for sure we just got a bunch
of Donald Trump's tax filings and
they're stunning and these are not look
full I think before we go any further I
should remind you these are not the tax
returns these are not like the
much-coveted recent personal tax returns
that Congress is trying to get from the
Treasury these are filings from 1985 to
1994 for Donald Trump but what they
reveal is absolutely fascinating you'll
remember that Donald Trump ran on being
a great business person and a deal maker
and in fact if you take that away if you
question Donald Trump's credentials as a
great business person and a deal maker
the guy has no credentials of any kind
it's sort of scary whether being a good
deal maker makes you a good president is
an open question but if you take that
pseudo credential away there's nothing
there at all but then you might remember
that during the 2016 campaign
people started rightly bringing up wait
wait a second hold on your businesses
have filed for bankruptcy many times are
you actually the great business person
you claim to be and Trump's explanation
at the time was that's because I was
using bankruptcy as a strategic tool to
my advantage it wasn't because my
businesses were failing businesses
wasn't that I made bad deals when my
business is declared bankruptcy
I was intelligently taking advantage of
bankruptcy protection there is a
fantastic new report in The New York
Times which tells us that that's very
very much untrue it looked at Donald
Trump's 1040 which is the the primary
federal tax form from 1985 to 1994 and
it is painting a very different picture
of Trump than genius businessman which
is what he has been touting for years
now over the 10-year period that the New
York Times reviewed Donald Trump
reported 1.17 billion dollars in losses
this was not common with high net worth
taxpayers at the time who would be
taking strategic losses for in order to
gain tax advantages Trump's losses were
outliers at the time they were
extraordinarily big and they were
genuine business losses these were not
strategic write downs or write offs or
use of sophisticated accounting measures
and in fact you know how Trump said that
finding ways to avoid paying taxes would
make him smart there was nothing smart
about this
Trump avoided federal income taxes for
eight of the 10 years that were reviewed
not because of tricky or sophisticated
accounting maneuvers he straight-up lost
a ton of money and therefore avoided
paying taxes during eight of the 10
years that the New York Times reviewed
and more importantly Donald Trump's
staff have been continuing to tell
massive and demonstrably false lies
about all of this the New York Times was
working on this story so they went to
Donald Trump's team to get a comment
about what they had uncovered and a
senior official said to them quote the
president got massive depreciation and
tax shelter because of large-scale
construction and subsidized developments
that is why the president has always
scoffed at the tax system and said you
need to change the tax laws you can make
a large income and not have to pay a
large amount of taxes this is just not
true okay this again makes it sound like
tax sheltering and subsidies and
depreciation losses created on paper
losses for
which allowed him to really
intelligently avoid taxes during eight
of those 10 years those are flat-out
lies and in fact a lawyer for Donald
Trump put out a statement saying that
what the New York Times is claiming
about Trump is quote demonstrably false
but when that lawyer was asked well
what's an example of something that's
demonstrably false if it's demonstrably
false demonstrate that it's false and
Trump's lawyer was unable to actually
cite a single specific claim that is
demonstrably false so what we've learned
here is that Donald Trump's tax
avoidance during these specific years
was not this enlightened proactive tax
strategy it was indicative of an
unstable and poorly run business that
was losing actual money period
now with Trump there's always usually
lurking in the background a dose of
hypocrisy that we can often find if we
look at his tweets and in fact Trump
tweeted in 2012 that quote half of
Americans don't pay income tax despite
crippling government debt as if they're
bad people well Trump was one of those
people for eight of the ten years that
the New York Times reviewed in the
mid-80s and the mid-90s and if we ever
actually got Donald Trump's more recent
tax returns my guess is we would find
out that he was also one of those people
not paying federal taxes at the same
time that he sent the tweet criticizing
that quote nearly half of Americans
don't pay income tax this morning Trump
clearly rattled by this put out a tweet
actually a to tweet word salad which
read quote real estate developers in the
1980s and 1990s more than thirty years
ago were entitled to massive write-offs
and depreciation which would if one was
actively building show losses and tax
losses in almost all cases much was
non-monetary sometimes considered tax
shelter you would get it by building or
even buying you always wanted to show
losses for tax purposes almost all real
estate developers did and often
renegotiate with banks it was sport
additionally the very old information
put out is a highly inaccurate fake news
hit job almost everything he said in
there was not true
the sort of common nature of what was
revealed in Trump's tax filings is not
actually common the idea that Donald
Trump's losses were only on paper losses
for the reasons he's citing is not true
I mean none of this is true it's
certainly not fake news and it's
actually been confirmed by looking at
the tax filings of his dad Fred Trump at
the time they were involved in a lot of
the same projects financially and
everything absolutely matches up so why
do we care about this we care about this
because number one Trump has gone crazy
to prevent his more recent tax returns
from being released and now we have
proof that Trump has lied about his tax
history he lies and his advisers lie
about the characterization of why he
shows losses on many years and we know
that it's very very likely on this basis
that Donald Trump is just not nearly as
rich as he has claimed to be he's an
egomaniac that would upset him if it
were confirmed but maybe more
importantly people this far in the read
people who were losing this much money
are a subject to are easier to
manipulate and to take advantage of
which is exactly what many of the
investigations into Trump are looking at
Russian oligarchs laundering money
through Trump's businesses over the more
recent years the problems with sketchy
Deutsche Bank dealings Saudis using
Trump's properties to launder money
later on today I'm going to tell you
about a connection to the
second-in-command and Nicolas Maduro
regime involved in real estate purchases
from Trump Organization businesses and
lastly if you look into the detail of
this investigation
you can pick almost any number that is
in the tax filings and investigate it
and you might find something something
sketchy like for example in 89
there was a 52 million dollar interest
payment what is that that number alone
might have an entire history behind it
which could be anything it could be
nothing or it could be more sketchy and
strange behavior we need Trump's more
recent tax returns
hopefully Democrats in the house can get
them sooner than later so that we can
actually learn the full scope of this
and most Americans want to see those tax
returns every other candidate in the
last 40 years has released their tax
return
we've got to see them and hopefully the
House Ways and Means Committee will
ultimately be able to get them what do
you think is the most notable thing
about Trump's 85 294 taxes I'm on
Twitter let me know at D Pakman and the
show is also on twitter at david pakman
show there's a woman who at an Iowa Town
Hall confronted anti Obamacare
Republican Senator Chuck Grassley over
the weekend and the video of the
confrontation has gone viral and I'm
gonna play it for you in a moment but to
set it up one of the saddest things
about conservative strict father
morality in the United States is the
complete and total lack of empathy that
pervades right-wing elected officials
who sort of subscribe to that political
philosophy or ideology and there are all
these stories we've heard over the years
of a homophobic anti-gay Republican who
learned their child's gay and suddenly
they have a change of heart
they're no longer as anti-gay they're no
longer as opposed to gay adoption or gay
marriage or whatever and I've explained
before okay it's good that these
right-wing homophobes suddenly saw LGBT
rights differently once it affected them
personally and they came over to the
right position but why does it need to
affect them personally before they can
actually empathize with other people who
are in a particular situation every
single time that a conservative
homophobe sees the light on gay rights
okay it's good but can't we as the
thinking species as Homo sapiens can't
we use abstract thinking to imagine what
it would be like to have a gay or
lesbian child and see that the law is
stacked against them and see that there
is discrimination implicit in our
society even if we don't actually have a
gay child and we've seen similar
confrontations happen to what I'm about
to show you along here'll health care
lines before where a sick person will
confront the lawmaker who wants to pass
a law that will lead to tons of people
losing their health care and some
portion of those people losing their
lives in Iowa over the weekend it was
Robin stone Robin stone has a
pre-existing condition she
confronted chuck grassley about how what
he wants to do with health care what
he's voted to do multiple times with the
affordable care act act puts her life at
risk and it escalated very quickly and I
understand why Robin stone got mad in
this video Grassley played this game
where he pretends that the threat to the
Affordable Care Act is that it might be
declared unconstitutional but Robin
stone reminds him well aside from the
constitutionality you voted to repeal
Obamacare multiple times and he gets all
blubber mouth than tries to make excuses
and then he actually if you're watching
you'll see him lean over and start to
berate this woman as if she's the stupid
one even though it's his position that
is unconscionable that's your question
so the Affordable Care Act is the law of
the land and soccer be repealed become
do you think there's going to be
the last time for veal was when McCain
voted the other way if there's no cancer
repeal of the now decided simply passing
this I live in three united states house
where the ten things so what he can so
what are you worried about Chuck
Grassley is calming her down by saying
don't worry you'll get treatment for
your pre-existing condition and you'll
get your medications because we have
Obamacare and she's saying that's what
I'm confronting you about you want to
get rid of Obamacare that's exactly why
I'm here asking you this question and he
insists well Obamacare is the law what
are you so worried about she's worried
about you chuck because you and your
cronies have voted to get rid of it
multiple times in the house it was what
60 votes in the Senate many votes she
says seven I don't know the exact number
and meanwhile and this is I mean let
this thing sink in for a moment the
sickness of this her taxes pay for Chuck
Grassley's health insurance right if
chuck Grassley had an ounce of moral
rectitude in his body
he would say you know what Robin I
empathize with you that sounds really
stressful I can't even imagine dealing
with your illness
while also being worried about losing
your care I don't want you to lose your
care here's why I think you will be
better off with an alternative to
Obamacare like I disagree with that
assertion unless you're saying
single-payer of some kind but at least
then we can have the real debate which
is which system works best dis chuck
Grassley actually have a viable
alternative to Obamacare that's not
Grassley's actual situation he doesn't
actually have a good alternative to
Obamacare but at least it be an honest
debate instead he's playing these games
well listen we have the Affordable Care
Act and I don't think it's going to be
found unconstitutional so don't worry
about it
which excuses him from having to
actively throw the Affordable Care Act
in the trash or at least try to every
time the Senate takes a vote on it truly
a disgusting human being chuck Grassley
who
be voted out immediately and
congratulations to Robin stone because
in those situations um it can be very
easy you know you think of your question
and you go in and you're ready and then
all of a sudden it's the middle of the
townhall and you get a chance to ask it
and she you know she like many others do
a good job of getting the question out
but then they immediately get sort of
hypnotized by the way that senators and
many lawmakers are able to sort of
defuse or distract or misdirect with
talking points like I don't think you
have to worry it's not going to be found
unconstitutional she didn't take her eye
off the ball which is forget about what
the Supreme Court decides if ever it
does about the constitutionality you
actively voted multiple times to remove
this from part of our healthcare
infrastructure which would potentially
kill me and she did a really great job
of not sort of losing the thread there
Grassley's gotta be voted out they've
all got to be voted out make sure you're
following the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show and while
you're there follow me at David Pakman
quick break back after this so we've got
some major breaking news on the show a
producer Pat Forde is sadly no longer
producer for the David Pakman show but
he's not gone he is now moving on to a
new shiny position being supervising
producer for the David Pakman show
that's been here for a couple years he's
not leaving he got a promotion we're
going to be ramping up a whole bunch of
new initiatives on the show the one sad
thing for some people about all this is
that you're not going to be hearing from
Pat nearly as much on the broadcast show
which includes podcast radio TV and sort
of like our normal YouTube clips but Pat
is going to be on the daily bonus show
so anyone who wants to continue to hear
and see Pat daily still Ken and as his
new initiatives get underway we're
actually going to be hearing more about
that from Pat on the bonus show
including what he's working on things
coming up on the show and a lot more so
it's a sort of bittersweet announcement
it's basically a result of Pat just has
a ton of stuff to do and
a lot more now that he is going to be
supervising the production of the show
and this has been you know going back to
the producer Lewis days this has been a
thing within the producer role for a
long time you might remember if you've
been with us this long when Lewis
started on the show as producer years
ago the idea was that he'd not be
participating in the show because of how
the studio was set up and a bunch of
different things but at the time because
Lewis's role was much smaller because
remember the show was like once every
other week Lewis started kind of chiming
in and some people like that some people
didn't like it and since then it's been
very kind of like off-again on-again
where sometimes we'd hear from Lewis
sometimes not depending what was going
on with the show that day or week same
with Pat but there is so much new stuff
going on now that it's just much more
time efficient for Pat to be working on
other aspects of the show while the show
is being produced rather than monitoring
the show's production minutes a minute
so we're going to be getting a lot more
done and that's the path forward and
I'll tell you about some of the exciting
things that are being added effective
immediately and or rolled out in the
next few weeks
number one by significant very popular
demand we are ramping up subtitles
captions and transcripts for the program
a ton of people have asked about this
some people it's because they're hard of
hearing other people just really like
being able to kind of read along with
what we're saying others want to be able
to read what's on the show rather than
actually watching the clips so we're
going to be immediately implementing
YouTube captions and subtitles and then
over the short to medium term we are
also going to be generating daily
transcripts of the show which you can
read you can read on your computer
you'll be able to read on your mobile
phone if you prefer to sort of like read
the show rather than listen to it when
you're commuting or whatever else so
that is one thing which is one of the
most common requests and it's actually
quite a bit of work surprisingly or not
for people who know what goes into that
and
hat is going to be spearheading that and
then also this is really great news
we're gonna be expanding our facebook
video presence to put the entire shows
clips on Facebook and you might be
saying what are you talking about David
I see your stuff on Facebook already
here's had it kind of how that has
evolved over time years ago we would
take a YouTube clip and we would embed
it on Facebook a couple of years ago
Facebook started allowing what we would
call native video uploads to Facebook
which means we're no longer embedding a
YouTube clip but we're directly
uploading the video to Facebook and you
see it in Facebook's video player and we
did that a little bit with like 30 or 40
percent of the show and then nine months
ago Facebook launched video monetization
on Facebook so that was an immediate
incentive to increase how much of the
show we were uploading to Facebook and
we upped it to like two thirds of the
daily show but it was making like no
money even though it was quote monetized
it was making I think like 30 bucks a
month for the entire month of you know
most of the last nine months but in the
last couple of months
facebook video revenue has started to go
up and because we're always looking for
alternatives to YouTube monetization
this is potentially a really good
revenue source for us that can keep sort
of the risk of any one platform failing
us lower by spreading out where we were
uploading video so starting effective
immediately we're kind of going to be
taking the plunge and we'll be putting
all of the Daily Show clips on both
YouTube and Facebook and that's another
project Pat is going to be overseeing
we're looking at posting classic viral
clips which were on YouTube but were
never on Facebook to the Facebook page
to expose some of the newer audience to
them people who haven't seen some of the
old classic viral stuff and then lastly
we're making a technical upgrade to the
show effective today which is going to
pretty significantly improve both the
video and audio quality of the show on
everything but the smallest screen so if
you watch the show on your phone on
mobile-phone you're probably not going
to notice much of a difference but if
you're watching on computer monitors
like 20 inches or larger or watching on
TV watching in high-definition you are
immediately going to see a pretty
significant visual improvement rolled
out over the next couple of days so
exciting stuff
thanks to everybody's support more
exciting announcements or upcoming sign
up for memberships of course that's the
best way to support us there's lots of
ways to support us now YouTube
memberships and Facebook subscriptions
or all of that stuff the best two
options are patreon where we get ninety
five percent of your contribution and
then website memberships where we get
about 97 percent of your contribution
everything - a 2.9 percent payment
processing fees so those remain the best
ways to support the show more stuff up
coming very soon and exciting
announcements I can't wait to tell you
about hey everybody I am genuinely glad
that you are with me today even the
trolls who are going to send me really
angry messages we have big news today in
the category of this might make Trump
lose his mind as I call it Donald
Trump's oldest son Donald Trump jr. has
been subpoenaed to testify by the Senate
Intelligence Committee and it's
important to remember that Republicans
control the Senate and therefore they
control the Senate Intelligence
Committee the chairman of the Senate
Intelligence Committee is Republican
Richard burr but it has actually been
that committee one of the few places
where there seems to be some sort of
bipartisan logic in dealing with the the
fiasco that is Donald Trump and
specifically the Senate Intelligence
Committee wants Donald Trump jr. to show
up and under oath to answer questions
about what were obviously lies the last
time he testified before the committee
related to his involvement in the Trump
Tower Moscow deal which ultimately
didn't end up going forward and Donald
Trump jr. previously testified about
that issue and he lied I mean he he
claimed that he had limited knowledge
about that project he claimed that there
was never really a plan it was never
really anything more than
notion that Michael Cohen thought up and
never really touched Donald Trump jr. in
any way but unfortunately since Donald
Trump jr. told those lies to the Senate
Intel committee we found out that jr.
was lying there were significant plans
for Trump Tower Moscow a site had been
selected a builder had been selected
there were architectural permanent plans
there were many meetings about it and
maybe most importantly as it relates to
Trump Trump juniors involvement
individually we heard from Donald
Trump's former attorney Michael Cohen
who's now in prison that he was
personally briefing both Donald Trump
jr. and Ivanka Trump and others about
this Trump Tower Moscow project and he
talked about it happening at least or
roughly 10 times here's just like a few
seconds from that testimony under
questioning from congressman Stephen
Lynch with his delightful Boston accent
who are the family members that you
briefed on the Trump Tower Moscow
project Don Trump jr. and Ivanka Trump
okay now with these in the regular
course of business or the president or
family requests of briefings this is the
regular course of business
do you recall there's a question on the
number of briefings do you recall how
many there might have been I'm sorry sir
do you recall how many of these
briefings there might have been it's
approximately 10 ok total all right this
is the opposite of what Donald Trump jr.
said under oath and now the leaders of
the Senate Intelligence Committee who
don't like being lied to including
Republican Richard burr ranking member a
Democrat Mark Warner they want Donald
Trump jr. to show up again now the fact
that there is even a subpoena is
significant here because it implies that
Donald Trump jr. already either ignored
or rejected an on subpoena request to
appear which arguably forced the
committee to issue the subpoena if they
actually are determined to get him to
answer questions once again and so this
is newsworthy for a few different
reasons one of those is that again this
is a republican-led committee and last
night I was wondering
is this going to cause infighting
between Trump and his administration and
the Republicans in the Senate and it
immediately has a source close to Donald
Trump jr. has said to CNBC that this is
quote an obvious PR stunt from a
so-called Republican senator if you want
the truth from Trump jr. if you don't
want him lying you now are apparently
only a so-called Republican according to
individuals close to Donald Trump jr. so
the infighting is starting right away
the expectation is that Trump jr. is
gonna fight this subpoena if possible
and the funniest little game they're
playing is the following CNBC is
reporting that the person close to Trump
Jr who is commenting about this says Don
is a private citizen now who has already
been cleared by special counsel Robert
Muller after a two-year investigation
are they really that dumb because there
are endless other investigations what I
and others said as soon as the Moller
investigation wrapped up was there are
12 to 14 maybe even more depending on
sort of where the lines are between
investigations there are more than a
dozen other investigations this isn't
the end they're going to keep talking to
witnesses and a lot of people on the
right said David come on it's over this
is it there's nothing else and then now
as we see the Senate Intelligence
Committee wants Donald Trump jr. back
and the argument they're making is he's
already been cleared by robert muller
that's one of like 15 different
investigations that are going on the
Moller probe was one thing did they
really think that it was all just going
to go away with the submission of the
Moller report or is this also a PR game
that they are playing more to curry
favor with the public than to actually
convince anybody who's in a position of
power I don't know but the most
important takeaway here is for a
republican-led committee to subpoena the
son of a Republican president in the
middle of all the chaos that's going on
right now with the Moller report with
William Barr they must believe that
Donald Trump jr. lied to them
sent
don't like being lied to if there's one
so if we think about like the different
echelons of priority among egotistical
elected officials very high on the list
is they don't like their power
questioned and that is very much
entangled with their partisanship they
want to be loyal to their party
one of the things that will more quickly
than almost anything else get Democrats
and Republicans united against some
third party is if they feel that their
position of authority and power has not
been respected and showing up and under
oath lying to them which is what there
is every indication Donald Trump jr. did
is a really quick way to get Republicans
and Democrats working together I hope
that he shows up if he fights the
subpoena we will report it and we will
tell you what ultimately happens with
this we predicted this would happen but
now it's time to really get our hands
sort of dirty because the Treasury led
by Trump flunky Stephen minuchin is
officially refusing to turn over Donald
Trump's tax returns which were requested
legally by congressman Richard Neal on
the basis of a law from the 1920s in his
role as chairman of the House Ways and
Means Committee the reason why minuchin
is refusing to turn over Trump's tax
returns is exactly the reason that we
predicted which is that the request from
Committee Chairman Richard Neal quotes
lacks a legitimate legislative purpose
which minuchin claims is required by the
Supreme Court and over to in order to
turn over tax returns unfortunately it
doesn't appear that that's actually the
case so I'm gonna explain this all to
you piece by piece and what you have to
remember is that Steven minuchin was
advised by Trump's Justice Department in
terms of how to not provide these tax
returns the Trump Justice Department is
led of course by none other than
Attorney General William bar a
professional at covering up the misdeeds
of presidents of the United States so
this is a loss if you were expecting
that today we would get Donald Trump's
tax returns but it's completely expected
and it's now going to set off a legal
battle that could actually be positive
in a way in the sense that it's going to
put Donald Trump's tax returns and more
importantly the fact that we haven't
seen them back in the news which
strategically is good for Democrats
because most Americans want to see
Donald Trump's taxes so that's the
strategy let's first go through the
legality of this there's a law that's
very clear
okay the law dates back to the 1920s I
think it's 24 but I'm going from memory
and the law says that if you're a member
of the House and Senate House or Senate
who is on a tax writing committee and
there are a number of committees that
have tax writing privileges you were
able to legally request the tax returns
of any taxpayer and that the IRS quote
shall furnish them period there are no
caveats there there are no ifs ands and
buts
you can request them if you're on one of
those committees and the IRS shall
furnish them doesn't allow for getting
help from the Justice Department to try
to block the request something which a
president can try but most citizens
would not be able to try to get the
Justice Department to help them block
the release of their tax returns but the
one question about all of this was is
there any precedent which says that if
you want to request a tax return from an
individual taxpayer on this basis using
this law that you need to justify a
legislative purpose for the request if
there is Richard Neil says the committee
is looking into whether mandatory IRS
audits of sitting presidents are good
policies so he's come up with a reason a
justification a legislative
justification if indeed one is needed
now the truth is that claiming you need
a reason is pretty dubious and the
reason that we know that's the case is
by looking at the law if you look at 26
US Code subsection 6103 doesn't say
anything about a legislative purpose it
says just quote upon written request
from the chairman of the Committee on
house on ways and means of the House of
Representatives the chairman of the
Committee on Finance of the Senate or
the chairman of the join
to Committee on taxation the secretary
of the Treasury that means shall furnish
such committee with any return or return
information specified in such request
except that any return or return
information which can be associated with
or otherwise identify directly or
indirectly a particular taxpayer shall
be furnished to such committee only when
sitting in closed executive session
unless such taxpayer otherwise consents
in writing to such disclosure so what it
says is that it has to be submitted
privately right in executive session
unless the taxpayer says it's okay for
it to be made more widely available it
says nothing about legislative purpose
minuchin has come up with a viable
explanation but it's nowhere in the law
it says that the secretary of the
treasury shall furnish not secretary of
the Treasury will analyze whether they
believe there is a legislative purpose
and evaluate whether in their opinion it
is a legitimate legislative purpose this
is arguably another act of obstruction
if Trump directed the Justice Department
to help the Treasury not follow the law
it is another instance and there are
already fourteen others which we'll talk
about later it is another instance of
obstructing the process of Justice it's
another checkbox so to speak in the list
of things Nixon resigned over which
Donald Trump has also done so that's the
legal side of it then there's the
strategy piece seeing Trump's tax
returns is very popular with Americans
it goes beyond just Democrats so simply
keeping this in the news is probably a
good strategy particularly as a reminder
as 2020 sort of heats up that Donald
Trump still hasn't released his taxes
and is actively using his Justice
Department and the Treasury to keep
those tax returns secrets so even if
this fails to get Trump's tax returns
over to the House Ways and Means
Committee which it very well may because
this is an administration that just
ignores subpoenas ignores requests and
they don't seem to be suffering any kind
to quences for that even if it doesn't
achieve that it still is likely a useful
thing for Democrats in 2020 just as a
reminder that we've still not seen those
tax returns and Donald Trump is going
even more out of his way than he has at
any previous point to prevent those tax
returns from going public last caveat if
you think that the tax returns if we saw
them would expose criminality by Trump I
don't think so I think the most likely
scenario is the taxes would expose the
Donald Trump is not nearly as wealthy as
he claims to be and maybe some of this
manipulation of property values higher
when it's advantageous and lower when
it's advantageous but I don't think
you're gonna get the bombshell
criminality that summer are sort of
hoping for if you disagree though let me
know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show